and how's morale today Dan life is good
you know I saw myself on a little
graphic that your team posted over there
Walter White's on there John McCain a
bunch of other people have no idea who
they are and who tees even on there and
it's nice to have my name a mention
amongst the great so I'll tell you that
right now Dan that's the type of thing
you get with Dan Patrick that you don't
get anywhere else
your biggest celebrity friend uh I don't
think anybody Dan you I guess you if you
would consider yourself a friend of mine
but I don't think anybody else really
admitted Terry maybe I mean that's a he
and I've gotten drunk a couple times
together I mean that's probably good
friendship I felt his balls for a while
now what do you guys talk about when
you're with Vinay Terry is it all about
the great things that vana Terry's done
in his career yeah remember when I
kicked at one against the Raiders
remember when I won that one don't know
what's right I want a couple of Super
Bowls finitary is only one about four
Super Bowls ready to get his fifth I
think he's gonna kick until he gets that
app makes that happen but he's one of
the coolest dudes ever and he's just
like he's one of my best friends even
though we have 15 years difference
between us and he's got 100 kids I got
no kids it's just it's your casual like
mancave conversation couple beers and
he's just an alpha male who kicks the
hell out of football so it's a good
relationship but I don't have the
friends like you have man I'm just a
regular guy likes to drink beer and eat
wings is there a different mentality
between punters and place kickers um
that's a good question
you know finitary and I have a very
similar mindset except for when it comes
to game winners finitary becomes like a
nice man he's impossible to even talk to
he doesn't talk to him but he stares
right through you and I think that's why
he has become who he's become but I
think punters are normally much more
athletic than kickers and I think that's
uh that's very well known so mindsets
are kind of a different thing because
each guy's does his own thing I didn't
really have that good of form I just
swung as hard as I possibly could every
single time I was on the field so I
think kickers and punters are all a
little weird a little bit different but
at the end we're all kind of the same
animal it's just us in the ball any
second thoughts on you're just
no no I'm having a great time with this
microphone thing that you've been doing
for a living for a long time I'm
enjoying the hell out of it I've had
conversations with a lot of incredible
people I got a chance to talk to
Edgerrin James last week and kind of
chitchat about his strip club in Miami
and all the great things he's doing down
in South Florida it's it's a lot of fun
kind of getting to learn things stuff
it's just it's just a lot of fun to
conversate with people and I've been
enjoying the hell out of it so when a
season comes around maybe Edgerrin James
is given back to the community with his
strip club is that what you're saying
well that's for the adults yeah he's
given back to the adults with his adult
ballet and then to the children he
basically Foster's like an entire
community down there like 180 kids come
through his house in the summer he takes
care of them kind of mentors them and
then at night he's taking care of all
the adults with uh good dance routine
you know it's a great thing he's got
going on down there the NFL competition
committee is proposing a couple of
things ten-minute overtimes as opposed
to 15 also you can't jump over the
center to block an extra point or a
field goal what do you think of these
proposed rule changes
well that jump over the center thing is
something that got us a few years ago
whenever we played New England it's a
it's a big deal for player safety mostly
because to do so both of your tackles
your defensive tackles have to lunge at
the feet of the guards so whenever the
nose tackle or when the tackle is lunge
at the feet of the guards there's a lot
of pressure on people's knees so then
people can jump over so it's not exactly
the jump over that people want to
eliminate it's the diving at the ankles
of the offensive guards you have to
protect for us kickers back there so I
respect that move I really enjoy
watching an animal though jump over a
Center and block a kick I mean that's
one of the most freaky athletic things
to watch because you have to time it up
perfectly you have to get it you have to
be so explosive to make that happen and
not touch anybody with the rule change
it made last year I think that's a very
interesting thing and I think since 2012
22 of the 83 overtime games have gone on
longer than 10 minutes I said being a
lot of ties I just don't want I don't
think we should be getting into the
business of ties that's just not our
sport that's not America either win or
you lose right there's no ties there's
none of that BS you're the winner you're
lose I think we should play in
till there's a winner I think there
should be I think at some point just
like there is a sudden death after each
person each team has a possession I
think you have to play till there's a
winner I don't think they should shorten
it I think they should say a play until
you find a winner and if you have a
short week with a Thursday game coming
up
sucks for you should have got the job
done quicker well so let me go back to
jumping over the center to try to block
a kick if I had a guy and and I'm
looking for the guy with the best
vertical on my roster why couldn't I
just have him jump over Center every
time in all it's gonna cost me is a
penalty so it's half the distance but if
I time it right I could change the game
certainly in overtime I don't know why
teams didn't try to do this man well I
don't we had it in our playbook a bunch
and they think the only thing you're
risking those if you get a penalty on
that you could possibly give up a first
down which for points is a big swing in
every single game so you're either gonna
get a field goal or a touchdown there if
you give up a first it's an extra point
if it's an extra point I mean you could
probably do that until you you want to
end it if you book towards the end of
games that's what New England did
against us it was kind of the last
touchdown we can either make it a one
point game or make it a tie game they
risked it they jumped it over it's all
game of risk and it's coaches sometimes
whenever you're in a close game that's
whenever you find out the good coaches
and I'm learning this about college
basketball too it's in those close games
where you find out if a search is good
or not it's not whether or not they can
get a team prepared or whatever it's
game time decisions and all those things
come from the head coach and for the
special teams coach making a play and I
think as long as they get rid of the
people diving at the ankles of the
guards
I think the jump over play is something
that's majestic to watch and I think
they should keep it in the game
personally but it's the diving at the
ankles that's the big deal what's the
on-field rule change you would like to
make if you had the power well I want
the refs to be I think you should be
able to challenge anything and I think
if you challenge it you get it right I
think you should you should keep your
challenge and I think the refs don't it
shouldn't have to go under their little
little teepee thing they got going on
over there I think they should just look
at the hundred foot Jumbotron that is
all in Forte in every single stadium
look up there and go oh that wasn't a
hold that isn't a 10-yard penalty which
would completely negate an entire Drive
they can call holding on any play at all
and all of a sudden its first in 20
you're just trying to get a good pun off
to get changed field position I think
ref should be able to look at the
jumbotron
and say oh that wasn't a hold we messed
that up let's keep it moving but it's
just there's so many things that you can
fix if you just allow refs to fix their
mistakes because rest on a bad spot
right now there's not only battling rule
changes changes they're also battling
technology where everybody at home can
see everything except for them and I
don't know why we just have to act like
they don't see the literally football
field-sized TV that's right above them
that has every single angle of the plane
I don't think a little bit of a day a
delay a 10-second delay to kind of
rewatch the replay and get the call
right is a problem I think that's
something they should think about I hope
you having fun all great to check in
with you and good luck in the celebrity
bracket challenge hey I appreciate you
greatly dam doc it's filled up my entire
bracket I made a couple differences so
it's not really a me thing this is an us
thing and I'm real excited about it
Walter White is gonna get beat and I'm
excited wait wait are you and Dan
dockage friendly now yeah we had a
little beef there for a little bit we
had a little battle cuz he was good
friends at Grigson high every hated the
guy so that's two different really
sparring heads kind of bulls battling
but we're real good friends and he ran
through that I don't pay attention to
college basketball I know nothing that's
probably why I'm doing so well but I
listen to my friends advice my smart
friends advice that's what successful
people do made a couple change WVU makes
a run Xavier sends me to Vegas for Bud
Light Buster's we're just keeping it
moving down
how do people listen to your broadcast
on barstool sports
well it's anywhere any podcasts are so
it's on iTunes stitcher google play and
all that stuff if people are just
getting iPhone though make everybody's
life easier that'd be great just find it
on iTunes Matt Magness show presented by
barstool sports Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday we have a good time here thank
you brother thank you dad that's Pat
McAfee former Colts punter cashed in and
well said that's it I'm done and I think
people thought at the time like wait a
minute you're gonna have second thoughts
here wait is he really doing this is
this a publicity stunt and then I
remember Pauly said Mac he's done like
he's done I go he's a Pro Bowl kicker
he's making a lot of money
he's kicking for a team that you know
could make a playoff run one of these
and then
Paulie said no he's done I went okay the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience